[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harwitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy it's a bloodbath at the state
department that's what the New York Post
recently reported saying Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson is cleaning house at
the state department according to a
report in Donald Trump's America so much
has happened so quickly to set the
nation on a course so decisively
different from the one it was on during
the regime of his disastrous socialist
internationalist predecessor that this
particular bit of good news was largely
overlooked but if a house cleaning at
the state department isn't a cause for
celebration nothing is many of those
says the New York Post who were let go
were on the building's seventh floor top
floor bigs the post adds that this is a
symbolically important sign to the rest
of the Diplomatic Corp that their new
boss has different priorities than the
last one pop the champagne and not only
that but this week's round of firings
marks the second time State Department
Personnel had been cleared out since
president Trump took office last month
four top officials were cleared out of
the building at the end of January so
says the post again break out the hats
and Hooters we can only hope that with
the departure of these failed State
Department officials that their failed
policies will be swept out along with
them Chief among these is the almost
universally held false idea that poverty
causes terrorism the United States has
wasted uncounted literally because a
great deal of it was in untraceable bags
full of cash billions of dollars in
Afghanistan Iraq Pakistan Egypt and
other countries in the wrongheaded
assumption that Muslims turn to Jihad
because they lack economic opportunities
and education American officials built
schools and hospitals thinking that they
were winning over the hearts and minds
of the locals 15 years thousands of
lives and hundreds of billions of
dollars later no significant number of
hearts and Minds have been won over this
is partly because the premise is wrong
the New York Times reported not long ago
that not long after the Attacks of
September 11th 2001 Alan B Krueger the
Princeton Economist tested the
widespread assumption that poverty was a
key factor in the making of a terrorist
Mr Krueger's analysis of economic
figures polls and data on suicide
bombers and hate groups found no link
between economic distress and terrorism
and then CNS news noted in September
20133 that according to a Rand
Corporation report on counterterrorism
prepared for the office of the Secretary
of Defense in 2019 terrorists are not
particularly impoverished uneducated or
afflicted by mental disease
demographically their most important
characteristic is normaly within their
environment terrorist leaders actually
tend to come from relatively privileged
backgrounds one of the authors of the
Rand report also found that according to
a number of academic studies terrorists
turn turn out to be more rather than
less educated than the general
population yet the analysis that poverty
causes terrorism has been applied and
reapplied and reapplied again this swamp
is in dire need of draining and in other
ways as well ever since 2011 it has been
the official Obama administration policy
to deny any connection between Islam and
terrorism this came as a result of an
October 19th 2011 letter from farana
Hera of Muslim Advocates to John Brennan
who was of course
then the assistant to the president on
National Security for Homeland Security
and counterterrorism and then became
Obama's CIA Chief the letter was signed
not just by Hera but by the leaders of
virtually all the significant Islamic
groups in the United States 57 Muslim
Arab and South Asian organizations many
with ties to the Hamas and Muslim
Brotherhood including the Council on
American Islamic relations the Islamic
Society of North America the Muslim
American society the Islamic circle of
North America Islamic relief USA and the
Muslim public affairs Council the letter
denounced what it characterized as US
government agency's use of biased false
and highly offensive training materials
about Muslims and Islam despite the
factual accuracy of the material about
which they were complaining the Muslim
groups demanded that the task force
Purge all federal government training
materials of biased materials Implement
a mandatory retraining program for FBI
agents US army officers and all federal
state and local law enforcement who have
been subjected to base biased training
and more to ensure that all law
enforcement officials would learn about
Islam and Jihad would be what the
signatories of this letter wanted them
to learn numerous books and
presentations that gave a perfectly
accurate view of Islam and Jihad were
removed from counterterror training
today this remains even in the Trump
Administration the policy of the US
government and it ensures that all too
many jihadis simply cannot be identified
as risks since the policy is to ignore
what insaner times would be taken as
warning signals Trump and Tillerson need
to reverse this President Trump has
often spoken about the threat from what
he calls radical Islamic terrorism he
needs to follow through and remove the
prohibitions on allowing agents to study
and understand the motivating ideology
behind the Jihad threat the swamp needs
draining indeed the bloodbath at the
state department is a good sign that the
US is on its way back to dry land I'm
Robert
[Music]
Spencer